LISA NASH: OK, great.
Welcome everyone.
Happy beautiful
afternoon in California.
My name is Lisa Nash, and I run
a non-profit called Blue Planet
Network.
And we are specifically
designed to help over
100 water and sanitation
organizations around the world,
who are doing amazing work
bringing water and sanitation
to people who do
not have it today,
but don't have the
tools they need
or the communication
they need to really do
the best job they can.
So our network of
110 organizations,
of which Sabore's Well
is one, work together
online on our online
platform in order
to share information,
share their learning,
and they use our mobile and
internet tools and services
in order to be able to
better manage their programs
and monitor them on
a long-term basis.
Because all the great
work in the world
goes down the drain
if something breaks,
someone doesn't
know how to fix it,
and suddenly all that work
you put into building a well
falls apart.
So I am particularly
excited today
to introduce Sabore, who is
in charge of Sabore's Well.
He's going to tell you about an
amazing story of an individual,
who saw a need in his community
for water and sanitation,
and has worked to
make it happen.
And how he's using technology,
as well as just amazing stories
to do it.
So I would encourage
all of you in this room
and online to go check out
Sabore's Well on our website,
www.blueplanetnetwork.org,
and you'll
be able to follow along as he
goes back to Kenya, implements
his program, and
you'll be able to meet
the people who are
impacted by his work
and the great
things that happen.
So with that, Sabore, I'm
going to turn it over to you.
SABORE OLE OYIE: Thank
you very much, Lisa,
for the good introduction.
And thank you everybody,
you're welcome,
and thank you kindly for
taking your time to come
and talk with me.
So my name's Sabore Ole Oyie.
I'm from Kenya, and I'm from
the original Narok county.
And I'm a Maasai by the tribe.
And I am happy to
be here today to be
able to speak out and tell
people what my vision is,
and what I want to
do for my community.
For the women of my community,
for the girls of my community,
and how to better their lives.
So as Lisa said,
that my vision is
to bring fresh water
to the community,
and to be able to liberate
women from walking between six
and eight miles, or even
up to 14 kilometers,
to go and collect water and
bring it back to the village.
And the water that they collect
is not even that clean water,
it's just contaminated
water, so I'm
really happy that I'm here to
be able to share it with you.
Thank you.
KAI WULFF: Welcome.
Welcome, Sabore.
My name-- I know
in Kenya we say,
my name's-- but my
name is Kai Wulff.
I work as the Access
Field Director for Google.
So my job is to connect
the other five billion.
Big theme is about
shared infrastructure,
like a borehole or a well,
is definitely something
that I would consider a
shared infrastructure.
I'm what I would call
a business shark.
So I'm not doing
philanthropy as my main job.
I'm basically looking at
the business cases as well.
And development in
a community-- and we
had a discussion about a
year ago, a little bit less
than a year ago--
development in a community
can be incubated, in my
opinion, by something
that is driven by philanthropy.
But, long term,
to be sustainable,
it needs a support network.
The support network
needs to come out
of extra incumbent
[INAUDIBLE] in the areas.
And I would love to
hear your thoughts
about what you think
will develop around
those wells in terms of
business opportunities
and in a way where
income is derived.
Because just to shorten the
way to walk to get water
is one aspect of it, but
what else can be done?
SABORE OLE OYIE: There
is one aspect of it.
And then the other
thing is about creating
a chance for girls
to go to school.
Because being at home
helping your parent
to go collect water or
maybe go collect firewood
is not the only thing
that you can do.
You can get an education
and become a better person
in future.
Work for a big company,
become-- go to high tech
and do stuff like that.
We believe that the girls in my
community are capable of that,
doing that.
And, also, for the
women in future,
after we get the
fast wells is we
are planning to have
maybe irrigation.
Like a small scheme
irrigation for the women
to be able to grow
their own crops.
KAI WULFF: You remember
the reservation
that many people had about the
Maasai being herdsmen, and not
necessarily in farming.
And this transition,
how it works culturally,
it will be of interest
to, again, share with us
why you think this change
of mindset will come about.
That you have now women being
empowered in a society where
women before-- no matter if they
had access to water or not--
were not necessarily empowered.
So what makes the
mind change work?
Do you think that it has
a long-term social impact
if women have more
to say in society?
There are statistics out there
that societies led by women
are more peaceful, more
inclusive, more prosperous
over time.
So tell us about the
challenges you're having.
You are an elder,
there are other elders.
It would be against what
I know about the Maasai
that I've interacted
with in my life
that everybody
agrees that easily.
So I would love that you share
a little bit with everybody,
and what are the
challenges, what
are the pushbacks
you are getting,
and what do you think is the
point where people will accept
the model that it's working,
that it's actually beneficial?
SABORE OLE OYIE: Our culture
is a very rich culture
and it's deeply
rooted into people.
And like [INAUDIBLE]
talking about the change
of set mind of coming to do
agriculture, most of the land
is now demarcated.
That these people own land.
And in order for them
to sustain themselves,
I believe in sometimes
to come there
will be not a lot of movement
of nomadics, moving the cows.
As you know, cows are
very special to us.
There will be no
movement of cows
going one place to another.
So the alternative is to grow
maize, wheat, and of which they
have already started
their planting it.
And educating a girl
is educating a village.
And I believe that as the women
are starting to be empowered,
getting the
education, and getting
to know what's going
around the world,
and understand what
are their rights,
it's something that
will change the culture.
And I believe it's
going to change
the culture on a positive way.
That we need that
as a direction we
need to go where they also need
to be part of decision making
within the society because
when you look at, for example,
maybe probably women can
start a women's group
that would create a
business for them.
To be able to take
care of the children,
help them, and buy clothes for
them, which the man can also
help on that.
So I think it is very
critical that they also
get the chance to expose
themselves, and become
better people in the future.
And I know it's hard
for our culture that
has been women less
powered people.
It's really hard for a culture
like that to change instantly,
it will have to take some time.
And it will have to
take a lot of commitment
between the youth
and the elder people,
going out and talking to people,
and campaigning for that.
That is the best thing.
And involving the
community too is
one of the most critical
things that you have to do.
KAI WULFF: So you're saying it's
not necessarily only a problem
of funding a well or
funding a business venture,
it's the whole ecosystem
you have to look at it.
That people believe
in it, that you
don't have too much pushback.
I don't let you
lose over pushback,
but tell me some of
the prejudices you got.
Last time we even
had the discussion
about the influence
of certain NGOs
or certain churches
into a community that
comes from a
different mindset that
tries to impose rather
than to include.
So I think that's
the utmost interest
because some people
believe there
is a silver pool that some
people believe you just
throw money at the problem
and every little thing
will be solved, or dig a
hole and then call it a well,
and then don't have the
support system with it.
SABORE OLE OYIE: I
think the best thing is
if you want to come up
and help the community,
you want to do something.
The best thing is to
go to them and ask them
what exactly they want, and what
exactly is important to them.
Because you might come up
with $100,000 and you tell us
I want you to build a church.
And the church is
not what we want.
We want a hospital, we want
water, we want a school.
So the best thing
is to go with them
and involve them and tell
them that this is what I want,
and find what they
want for you to do.
For now, for our project is not
involving a big NGO coming in
to say that this
is what we want.
I, myself, and some other
people in my-- my partners
that I work with just came
out with this is our vision
and this is what we want to do.
And this was my idea to
come up that we need water
to be able to liberate these
women from going there.
So the challenge is we think
that people who come in
and how we can be able
to include them within us
so they have to
accept what we want,
not coming in and saying that
this is what I want you to do.
So actually those are
the most challenges.
And when you look
at the big NGOs,
the big NGOs comes in
with an objection of,
we want you to do this.
In business, we want you to
buy cows and, for example,
[INAUDIBLE].
Do this and this and this.
We want you to go
to school, we want
you to buy cows and keep
it as a business of which
is really good because this
is empowering them and trying
to improve their life.
But it depends on
what people need most.
KAI WULFF: The learning is
there's no one size fits all,
and you can't use the same
blueprint of development
all over Africa, not even
within two Maasai communities
you would be able to
just replicate what
one has been doing because
the need in the other
might be wild [INAUDIBLE]
killing the fields,
or a fence might be more
useful than a water well
in another community.
SABORE OLE OYIE:
And that is true.
KAI WULFF: So that is what
we discussed last time
as well is about let
the community decide
what has the most benefit.
How would it, in
your opinion, work
if, after the first
philanthropic-driven
approaches, now if you see
the need in the community,
need for businessmen is
always equal to income.
So if you have after a
certain incubation phase,
do you see that the
whole Model of 8
of incubating this could
be-- sooner or later--
be turned around into loans
and funding of businesses.
So rather than
funding the borehole
as a donation, which you
have to do in the beginning
to incubate the whole
thing, long term, funding
other boreholes and
infrastructure as a loan, which
is payable back so which
gives the community more power
to say what I want
to do with the money
that I'm borrowing rather than
having to live with, I get
money and because I give
you the money for free
I can dictate what
you're supposed to do.
Do you think that's a
model that could work?
SABORE OLE OYIE: For now,
we are still a very young,
starting to be growing up as a
community-based organization.
And I think in
the future, as far
as we go-- because my
recent past of my vision
was to build two wells.
But after attending a
program in Santa Clara
about global leaders
for justice sponsored
by an organization called
GLWN, Global Women Leadership
Network, I changed my
vision into 400 wells.
So to be able to do that, this
will take up some time for me
and the community to be able
to grow, and be able to sustain
themselves in
maintaining the wells,
and how much money
comes out of the wells.
Because eventually we'll have to
chart a certain amount of money
to be able to maintain it
and do other needed stuff
within the borehole.
So anything that comes out
of there is the fast priority
will pay a school
fee for a girl.
And this girl will
believe if she
goes to school she can
bring back to the village
and give it back to the village.
So it's something that
eventually in the future
we will work, depending
on how much income we'll
get from getting the borehole.
If it is enough to sustain
the borehole, pay the school
fees for a certain number of
girls, and then the remaining
we can ask the women to do
what they want with the money.
If they want to
start a women group,
if they want to do
an irrigation scheme,
it depends on what they will do.
KAI WULFF: So to
summarize it, it's
basically like venture capital.
Just that you don't expect
the return in two years,
but you're looking at
the generation of change
in a society that then
has all the business
cases attached to it.
So people can pay for the
services they're receiving,
people can see them as business
cases, can roll out themselves.
Because I'm always saying
there is not enough money
even if you collect
all the surplus money
that people have
to do everything
as a philanthropic exercise.
It needs to be ultimately driven
by the principals of service
rendered, service paid.
SABORE OLE OYIE: So
this is something
that is, no, we're not looking
to do it just right now.
We're looking on a sustainable
project that if I'm not there
somebody else will be able to
see that something was done
here, and we need to continue
with what Sabore or other women
have been doing, we
need to continue.
So it's a long-time project.
KAI WULFF: OK and
then, hopefully, it
will be replicated in other
communities in their flavor.
SABORE OLE OYIE: Correct.
It's not only going
to be in my community.
As time goes and we
have the resources,
we will expand it because
this is not my last one,
I'll have to keep going.
KAI WULFF: I just
hope you are not then
going to the other community
and say, you need a borehole,
you need to--
SABORE OLE OYIE:
No, no, no, no, no.
It's all up to them.
I'll propose to them that,
do you guys need water.
Because the places
that I'm thinking
that need water is
a wide area, and I
know what they're going through.
The same thing that
we are going through
is also what they are
also going through.
So if I propose to them
and that is what they want,
you go with them.
it's good to throw an idea and
tell people that, you guys,
this is what you need, and, I
know, they're very critical,
they need them.
KAI WULFF: And you know my
passion, where there is water,
the next step would be how
do we generate energy that
is sustainable,
that's is not running
on diesel that needs
to be imported.
How do we create communication
around such a location
to make it even more
compelling to go there,
to push more content.
This is what I see as a
shared infrastructure.
It's not only just
for water, it's
a new community center
that's hopefully
going to be generated.
SABORE OLE OYIE: I
really like your idea
of bringing on the
technology to there to where
the [INAUDIBLE] so that
[INAUDIBLE] that communication
with that because I think
we have to have both things.
We have to keep
our culture, which
is something that has been
lost in some societies.
And we like to have
it, but we also
have to have
technology and learn
what's going on in the world.
Because, for example, if
I go back to the village
I can now use my computer,
I can use my phone.
And I would like
any other person
to be able to do
that in my village.
So that we can also know what
is going on around the world,
and help people
understand what are
the importance of having
education as a way
to progress their life.
KAI WULFF: I'm always saying
if you connect the community,
it's usually the world
learning more about out
of the community than
actually the other way around.
So the diversity of ideas,
the diversity of cultures
makes everybody's life richer.
So if you contribute as a small
community with 1,000 people
through the internet society,
which is 2, 3 billion,
the trade balance
should be in a way
that you are
actually contributing
more to the
ecosystem that you're
taking out of the ecosystem.
SABORE OLE OYIE: Correct.
KAI WULFF: And that's
very encouraging
to see that you want
to keep the culture.
That you're saying , no, no, no,
the first thing we want to do
is once we have the borehole
and once we have internet,
we are going to dress in
designer jeans and just want
to sit and write applications
for mobile phones.
As much as I love people writing
applications for mobile phones,
but it can't be--
in my opinion--
the ultimate outcome that
everybody in the world
only writes applications.
So the application needs
to serve something.
And I had a discussion
this morning with somebody
about how he would invest
in your business case
in rural Africa.
Now, of course, I usually
don't speak about rural Africa.
I'm very confident that
within a five-kilometer radius
you might have three different
cultures clashing together
in Africa, but I was
asking and everything
was driven about
organization, and those people
should move into the city.
And my challenge
was, and who's going
to feed the world if
everybody lives in the city?
Where is the food
going to come from?
From rooftops?
SABORE OLE OYIE: That is true
because we have people back
at home who have got education,
and they go to the city
and become big people, lawyers
and working in companies,
but they still come
back to the village.
I think you can hold
both things in one.
You can hold your
spear on the left hand
and you can hold a
pen on the right hand.
And that means you
can be in both worlds.
KAI WULFF: Not as you
go through a TSA check.
SABORE OLE OYIE: No.
KAI WULFF: Very challenging,
very challenging.
I think they think this
way worse than a pocket
knife or a nail clipper.
SABORE OLE OYIE:
So I think this is
what the people
should understand.
That you need to have both.
You don't have be in the city.
If you go to school, you
don't remain back in the city
and work in the city.
Like you said, who is
going to feed the world?
They need to go
back in the village
and be able to be there, and
also be able to contribute back
to the community for
what they have learned.
KAI WULFF: That's
very encouraging.
I think we open the floor
for a few questions,
and then if I have any
crazy questions for you
I will just interject.
SABORE OLE OYIE: I
want to say thank you
to [INAUDIBLE], who is actually
the person who helped me out
with my vision.
I had the vision for the
proposal for about four years.
I didn't know what to
do until I met her,
and I can see now my vision
is becoming to a reality.
KAI WULFF: And if you
need a business advisor,
in terms of fund counseling--
SABORE OLE OYIE: Definitely.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Could you speak
about the challenges
of drilling wells in Kenya?
In particular, what
type of material
do you need to go through?
How difficult is the
material to penetrate?
How deep do you
typically have to go?
How large are these wells?
And what kind of water flow
can you expect out one?
So what are those challenges?
SABORE OLE OYIE: According
to the hydrological survey
that we have done,
because we have
to go through a
hydrological survey,
and the hydrological
survey has to be approved
by the government as
a registered engineer.
And we went through that
and we got the report.
And the maximum-- the
deepest maximum we can go
is 250 meters, and the
minimum is 120 meters.
And, according to his
report, that there
was enough water that it can
produce around 8,000 liters
in one hour.
AUDIENCE: Wow.
SABORE OLE OYIE: So
there was enough water.
And the other challenge
is also to be approved
by the government to be
able to get an organization
to drill the boreholes.
And, as we don't have our own
company that drills the well,
we have to find out
the companies that
are really experienced--
there are a lot of shady work
that you can find everywhere.
So we have to be very keen
on looking for the best
company that can
drill the boreholes.
And we just pay them, they bring
all the material that we need.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
KAI WULFF: Maybe
I can add, there
were a lot of challenges in
people digging wild boreholes.
especially affluent
people within the city.
Like in Nairobi, the
groundwater levels for this
have dropped tremendously
because everybody
was drilling a wild borehole.
And people were drilling
boreholes for irrigation
purposes, but went
into what's called
the ice in the salt layers.
So after awhile the
fields become unusable.
So I have to give kudos
to the Kenyan government
to be now very
restrictive in not
just every NGO or every
farmer or everybody
coming up and just
digging a borehole.
And there are other areas
where 120 meters is not
a wild borehole,
that's difficult to do.
But you have other areas where
the groundwater levels are
much lower, and you
don't want a scenario
that the fields get spoiled
by salt content in the ground
or that the water you
pump out gets contaminated
by the graveyard next door.
And these were all cases,
actual cases, that happened.
And, hopefully,
with the involvement
of the communities,
the community,
itself, if it's educated
will push governments there
and in other countries
to say, wait a minute,
it's a good thing, it needs
to be handled in a proper way.
And if everything happens
transparently and there
is no, what we call
[? kitu kidogo ?],
a little something
that needs to be paid,
then this is a very
positive development.
And, as I said, I'm
usually very skeptical when
it comes to giving
kudos to government
regulations
overregulating, but when
it comes to water sanitation,
natural resources that
can easily backfire,
that's a very good thing.
And I have to say, I
looked at the project
and there was a lot of
due diligence done on
not to create those problems.
AUDIENCE: A follow-up
question to that
is Kenya has lots of
wonderful resources--
beautiful oceanfronts,
lakes, it's
the number one
safari destination
for tourists who come there.
Anyway, along those lines,
has any consideration--
I know that the population
doesn't typically
exist in those
areas, but is there
any consideration going forward
to desalinization plants that
could draw from the oceans
or water treatment plants
could draw from the lakes, or is
this strictly a well endeavor?
SABORE OLE OYIE:
First of all, I think
we live about-- to
where I live, I'll
say 6 or 700 kilometers away
from the sea, very far away.
And we don't have
a lake around us.
There are a few lakes in Kenya
-- Lake Naivasha, Lake Nakuru,
Lake Victoria Lake Turkana.
There are a few lakes in Kanya,
but we are totally far away.
We have a river, which is
called the Ewaso Ng'iro.
There are two Ewaso Ng'iros.
There is North [INAUDIBLE]
Ewaso Ng'iro and there is South
[INAUDIBLE] Ewaso Ng'iro.
And we are in the
South [INAUDIBLE] Ewaso
Ng'iro, and from where I live
it's about seven kilometers
away from the river.
So drawing that
water from the river,
it will take a lot of
resources, and cleaning it,
and trying to purify the water
will take a lot of resources.
So the best thing to
do is the boreholes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SABORE OLE OYIE: And
thank you very much.
I'm a cultural ambassador
from my country
so I'm really happy
when you say it's
one of the best destinations.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
is important--
KAI WULFF: He said
it's the best--
SABORE OLE OYIE: The best.
KAI WULFF: --We could never
say that because we're biased,
but he says it's the best.
AUDIENCE: I just wondered,
how do you find the world?
I know in Northern
California they often
bring these mystical people
out, dowsers with the rod
and they'll pull
you up and down,
because they say half the
time the company comes out,
they can't find it,
they're drilling blind
even though they've
done some kind of study,
but these witch
doctors or whatever
can actually half
the time find it.
How do they find where the
well is in the first place,
and where to drill?
SABORE OLE OYIE: Honestly, I'm
not really sure how they do it
and how they sense it,
but they have metal.
They use a kind of metal.
This engineer was using a kind
of metal near the machine,
that he was reading
some numbers,
and that's how he said that--
KAI WULFF: Ground electricity
resistance levels.
You can measure
out magnet fields
that are giving you an
indication where underground
there should be a flow because
it doesn't help you if you just
drill down and you
have stale groundwater.
You need to have
some kind of flow.
So you need earth
underneath with stones
that allow the movement of
water, because it's a bipole,
it creates a magnet field.
And that's the same
principle those guys are
using because they're
very sensible to this.
My dad and myself we
could do this as a game.
I wouldn't do it professionally,
but we had a pretty good hit
rate.
It's a subconscious thing.
People or animals
react to magnet fields.
It's no magic involved with it.
It's simply that you
have to believe in it,
and you have to be
loose enough to do it.
AUDIENCE: In followup,
are there any issues
with the well going dry?
How do you know that there's
enough water there every year
for 100 years, will there be
water, or is that an issue?
If the well goes dry [INAUDIBLE]
do something like that?
SABORE OLE OYIE: I think that
one will depend, actually,
on the usage of water.
And how much is the
water being used,
and how much you have gone deep
to the where the source is.
Because, according to
the report, he said
there are 8,000
liters in one hour.
I think that is enough for us.
So we believe in-- you
never know about nature.
You cannot predict
when it's going to end,
but we believe it's going
to last for a long time.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering,
considering this a community
effort, what kind of
individual participation
are you looking
at for people that
are not based in the community?
SABORE OLE OYIE:
Mostly what we like
is we will appreciate the
advise, like people like Kai,
to be able to come and give
us an advice on what can we
do in the future.
And I think when you're also
constructing the borehole,
we also need people to come and
help volunteer and do something
to be able to help us building
the structure of the house,
and also giving us advice
on how to maintain.
And mostly is on how
we can get the fundings
for the next project.
KAI WULFF: I would give
you a business case.
Open a little tent camp
for volunteers to come over
and help with the work, and
sell the spaces in the tent camp
and then be a moving
camp and a builder.
So you never know.
Everything is driven
by business in the end.
AUDIENCE: Absolutely.
KAI WULFF: I would
like to say thank you
for everybody that's worked
very, very hard on the project.
I think Sabore has
a few things to sell
that support the cause as well.
And I'm very, very happy
to be aligned with it
and to help with
advice and whatever
else I can do for
my old home, Kenya.
SABORE OLE OYIE: Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Thank you very much
for coming, and we also
have some stuff that we support
women widows because they're
not supposed to remarry again.
So we also support them to
take their children to school.
So I bring the beadword
for them that they
make that I can take
something back to them.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]